when you talk about come away which is a
fantastic idea blending the world of
of peter pan uh with alice in wonderland
and it's this terrific story and then
you add to that
you michael kane has a cameo
in this film and uh it's hard for me to
think of
and as you know uh as someone from the
uk i mean it's hard for me to think of a
more iconic
actor in the world but it must have been
very
strange for you to be acting with
michael kane
it it was beyond strange
it was anyone who sees the film
the toughest piece of acting i have to
do in come away
is my scenes with michael kane but not
for the reasons people may think
it's because i couldn't get out of my
head
the fact that it felt like michael caine
was doing an impersonation of michael
kane
[Music]
it was it was so weird because that
voice is
so iconic and and every time he would
speak
i would be like stop that stop stop
doing you
why are you doing you it was
so weird it was so
weird even between takes he would talk
to me
and i would find myself thinking stop it
[Laughter]
i don't know if you've seen the uh you
know when you look at the film and you
have your scenes with michael caine
there's actually
you you look towards camera and you go
king
totally break character and it's really
my only
david it's my only problem with the film
[Laughter]
i wonder exactly how i felt inside by
the way i
i want to make sure we show this clip of
uh from uh from come away anything you
want to say about this clip before we
show it
yeah i well you know i just love this
film it's it's it
it it is a film that i wish i had when i
was 12 years old uh
you know in terms of the images you're
about to see and this is me having a
conversation
with my son that is full of wonder it's
the it's the kind of conversation i have
with my kids but i very rarely get to
see on film all right let's take a look
at this clip from come away
is it for old mr brown right you are
the golden hind the first ship
to sail all the way around
the globe imagine what it must be like
to see the whole world to sail
the indian ocean and the pacific
and maybe even discover new
plans ah
the things she must have seen